oh
[Musique]
d
les matins c'est un peu cheap ou
respiratoires je pars en forêt c'est
très important pour moi
cette période où je vis de ma tête et où
j'absorbe la nature ce qui va me
permettre de créer plus tard le végétal
est une source d'inspiration la fougère
typiquement solognote et puis c'est vers
tellement différent je suis peintre
animalier depuis une vingtaine d'années
et depuis 4 5 ans l'envi l'envi de la
décoration a fait que je me suis dirigé
vers le tissu et vers le travail de
graphiste textile mon premier travail
est d'abord un dessin préparatoire que
je vais utiliser ensuite sur mon
ordinateur pour créer mais graphisme à
imprimer
[Musique]
donc là j'ai mon brocard qui revient de
chez l'imprimeur donc c'était un travail
de peinture au départ et là il est
installé sur sont là donc je vais
préparer un coussin et ensuite je vais
passer à la machine à coudre
je montre un petit peu l'étendue des
animaux que j'ai dessiné et préparer
pour des coussins
donc on a une petite biche mon petit
chouchou le renard que je décline aussi
sur des petites pochettes et en ce
moment je travaille pas mal aussi les
plumes alors le petit martin pêcheur et
si on a des avocettes voilà et puis le
chevreuil traditionnellement donc j'ai
réalisé tout à l'heure et on le retrouve
sur un gros plaide
[Musique]
donc du coup myriam j'ai rapporté
quelques petites nouveautés
bonjour dans l'armoire
je te laisse mettre en place nous sommes
à cheverny dans notre petite boutique
qui s'appelle vivre côté sologne
donc nous sommes une douzaine de
créateurs et ici ça nous permet de venir
à la rencontre de nos clients et d'avoir
des seins des jolies lieu pour exposer
la sologne c'est d'abord une terre
d'adoption jeu elle m'a adopté il y a
trente ans et je me sens profondément
enracinée c'est vraiment effectivement
ma source d'inspiration principale qui
se fait au niveau de la faune ou de la
flore
[Musique]